el jefe bombero legal en y tiene grabado
a fuego el día en el que las alarmas
saltaron era febrero y la guerra había
empezado su ciudad estaba en llamas
esto es un barrio del sureste de jarquil
una zona humilde en la que quedan los
ciudadanos que no han podido oír y la
artillería aterroriza
es un misil es un misil
cuatro días tardaron los bomberos de
jardín en apagar el fuego que quemó este
edificio uno de los primeros que fueron
atacados cuando empezó esta guerra que
continúa desde hace más de dos meses
acompañamos a los bomberos de jarquín en
una jornada de trabajo con la invasión
rusa doblan turnos y corren más riesgos
para rescatar a las personas y reparar
los destrozos provocados por el
conflicto
ha
ocurrido que a veces cuando luchábamos
contra el fuego bombardearon de nuevo ha
habido momentos trágicos algunos de mi
equipo murieron así en esta zona de
presenciado 15 casos de dobles disparos
al mismo blanco en muy poco tiempo que
yo pongo por equipo industrial número 1
lo
que explica que a veces los proyectiles
han caído mientras luchaban contra el
fuego sin embargo la entrevista se
interrumpe por otro bombardeo
pero el día sigue este equipo todavía
tiene varias horas de trabajo por
delante algunos hacen llamadas por
teléfonos otros bromea para distender la
atención en vista de lo que todas
ocurren
en el cuartel de la encargada de la zona
right at electrónica a la recibe tres
veces más llamadas que antes de la
guerra es terrible que sea posible que
allí debajo haya gente en una guerra tan
compleja o legal en nyc y su equipo
tienen claro su papel su prioridad es
salvar vidas
[Música]